did the rules change regarding this
Mandalorian tool in the season 3 finale
or is there an explanation hidden in
plain sight there have been many major
battles across the Mandalorian and its
multiple Seasons but few of them can
match the scale and intensity of the
battle of Mandalore in the season 3
finale episode as DIN jarin and grogu
have their climactic confrontation with
moth Gideon so too do din's fellow
mandalorians engage in their own big
fight to retake their home planet once
and for all it all makes for another
epic Star Wars battle aside from one
tiny problem one part of the on-screen
Skirmish doesn't really make sense to
some fans throughout the battle
audiences see various characters
particularly ax woes and his fellow
Mandalorian Fighters using jetpacks for
traversal this isn't anything new for
the show as a previous episode of the
Mandalorian also saw characters
employing jet packs however the exact
manner in which this piece of gear is
used in the finale May conflict with an
important bit of information that may
have been established in the series just
a few episodes prior during the season 3
finale of the Mandalorian ax wolves uses
a jet pack to manually fly into space
and later Propel himself back to
mandalore's surface considering the
show's sci-fi trappings there's not much
of an issue with that plot point or at
least there wouldn't be if it didn't
seem to violate the in-universe rules
that the Mandalorian had set for itself
earlier in the very same season back in
season 3 episode 4 of the Mandalorian it
seems to be established that jetpacks in
the Star Wars Universe can only be used
to carry their users a relatively short
distance if that's true it makes sense
to add such a limitation to what would
otherwise be a pretty overpowered piece
of gear especially as the story required
a reason that the group couldn't simply
pursue their prey with jetpacks granted
it seems like the bigger problem was the
noise that the jetpacks would make
the mountains are too high if we use jet
packs the Beast will hear
either way they didn't clarify exactly
how far the jetpacks could take them if
fully fueled up the problem for some
fans is that this seeming limitation is
tossed out the window in the season 3
finale according to them axwobs
shouldn't be able to take himself all
the way up into space with a Star Wars
jetpack let alone still have the fuel to
fly out of the ship before it crashes to
the surface all in all if it is a
continuity error it's a fairly minor one
that doesn't really affect the overall
quality of the battle or the episode
some Die Hard fans of the Mandalorian
also took notice of the apparent
discrepancy in the use of jetpacks
during the season 3 finale as one Reddit
user put it in their list of issues with
the episode The jetpack's limitation was
a pretty big issue in a previous
foundling episode but now someone can
just hit low orbit with no problem
nonetheless one fan has pushed back on
the critique by offering a theory that
could possibly explain why the jetpacks
in the season 3 finale seem to be so
much more powerful compared to the ones
featured in season 3 episode 4. The Fan
suggests that there might EPA difference
in build quality between the jetpacks
used by the children of the watch and
the ones used by ax wolves and his
fellow mandalorians they wrote I'm
thinking the children of the watch group
were making do with whatever they could
find building their equipment in a cave
with a box of scraps by contrast the
Mandalorian resistance had access to
regular society and would naturally be
able to take advantage of better tools
and equipment another answer could be
that they simply had more fuel prepared
for the battle in contrast to getting
taken unprepared by the Raptor before
they could top off the tank neither
theory has been explicitly confirmed
leaving fans to make up their own minds
about whether this is a continuity error
or simply a subtle bit of Storytelling
thank you